[Musique]
a
un
Anthony
[Musique]
anony Anthony
il EX [
Musique]
dis [
Musique] [
Musique]
ouais
[Musique]
tu aimes la cuisine indienne ouais tu aimes tu
aimes la cuisine indienne oui
vraiment c'est la première  la fois c'est la première fois que tu
vas en Inde
oui oh euh et toi c'est la première fois que
tu prends l'
avion sur Andre c'est la première fois que tu
prends l'avion et toi la première fois que tu
prends l'avion
non je pensais que c'était toi qui as l'air d'avoir
peur je'  J'ai
peur de quoi de quoi de l'
avion des gens dans l'
avion où était-ce ce n'est
pas l'Inde voici qu'est-ce que l'Inde
tout ce que tu aimes la nourriture indienne oui vraiment c'est la
première fois que tu vas en Inde
oui et toi c'est la première fois que tu y vas
dans
l'avion je pensais que c'était parce que tu as l'air
effrayé je suis
AF de quoi dans l'avion
non des gens dans
le je ne dois pas parler je ne dois pas
trop parler je ne parle pas je ne parle pas je ne parle pas  ne parle pas
trop ou alors on y
retourne une fois que je parle
trop puis je reviens BR là où
c'était ce
n'est pas l'Inde
ici c'est
déjà l'Inde tu es un
n en Inde nous disons enfants de
Dieu en Inde nous disons enfants de Dieu
maintenant c'est
pire avant qu'on dise
[Applaudissements] les
chai
vont
bien
ok tu aimes la nourriture indienne oui
vraiment la première fois que tu vas en Inde oui euh
Andrew c'est la première fois euh tu
prends l'avion tu es dans l'Andrew la
première fois que tu montes dans l'
avion
non  c'est que tu avais l'air effrayé je pensais que
c'était tu avais l'air
effrayé j'ai peur de
quoi de quoi de quoi de l'
avion
non des gens dans le
SL je ne parle pas je ne parle pas
trop tout le plan reviendra une fois que je
ne faites pas
grand-chose en arrière où était-ce
[Musique]
pour ou après moi la
[Musique] étrangère
avant
où c'était l'
Inde mais ce n'est pas l'Inde
ici Les
Européens
aiment tellement l'Inde
euh je ne suis pas
un euh les enfants de  Dieu ils sont le
poète du PO les enfants de Dieu ils
sont le prêtre des
pauvres
comme non
non du
prêtre du
PO bien sûr bien sûr
les enfants de Dieu sont le
prêtre du
PO bien sûr
non ils ne peuvent pas  dors tranquillement
brah et donc rien ne
changera rien ne changera ouais
ok là des
pauvres
euh es-tu euh enfants de Dieu c'était
avant ah non es-tu un Chandal qu'est-ce que hein
enfants de Dieu es-tu Chandal
il n'y a pas une semaine
sans qu'on ait des enfants  tout va
bien, les enfants de Dieu sont les plus pauvres des
pauvres, pas
[Applaudissements]
êtes-vous toujours un
d
[
Musique] [Musique]
s [Musique
]
[Musique]
pour pour [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Applaudissements]
orteil
[Applaudissements  ]
[Musique]
besoin de
tu aimes la cuisine indienne oui très [
Musique]
beaucoup c'est la première fois que tu vas en Inde
oui et toi non c'est la première fois que tu
prends
l'avion
non c'est vrai
je pensais que c'était tu avais peur je
'  j'ai
peur non de quoi de l'
avion les gens dans l'
avion je ne
parle pas je ne parle pas
trop une fois j'ai trop parlé et l'
avion est
reparti où où était-il en
Inde ce n'est pas l'Inde ici c'est tout
[  Musique]
Inde
[Musique]
êtes-vous
incapable en Inde nous disons en
Inde en Inde nous disons enfants de
Dieu
je
voudrais bien ok ok tu aimes la cuisine indienne
oui vraiment c'est la première fois que tu vas en
Inde
oui André c'est la première fois que tu y vas  dans
l'avion
non je pensais que c'était tu avais l'air effrayé j'ai
peur de quoi dans l'avion je connais tous les
gens dans l'
avion je ne parle pas je ne parle pas
trop tout le plan on revient une fois je parle
trop et  le plan est
revenu où où était-il en Inde ce
n'est pas l'Inde
ici et vous vous êtes vous D
non directeur pas avant
spech
avant
spee pour le discours avant
spe étranger
oui c'est la
première fois que vous allez en Inde oui et vous
c'est la première fois que vous  je prends l'avion
non euh je pensais euh je pensais que c'était tu avais l'air
effrayé j'ai
peur de quoi de
l'avion
en Inde on
dit en Inde on dit enfants de Dieu en
Inde on dit enfants de Dieu maintenant ça
marche avant de dire
Chandal sont  toi
Chandal
oui
[Musique]
e [
Musique] [Musique]
avant [Musique] [
Musique]
pour [
Musique] [
Musique]
pour [Musique] [Musique]
[Musique]
pour [
Musique]
avant chute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
speee
avant
pour quelqu'un Ste le
noir [
Musique]
joue
avant pour pour de
l'argent
encore
pour
[Musique] avant avant non non non non non non non Non avant, je ne sais
pas
où
sympa
avant
[Musique]
pour parler
étranger
ok c'est la première fois que tu pars en Inde oui
Andrew c'est la première fois que tu prends
l'avion
non je pensais que c'était tu avais l'air
effrayé j'ai
peur de quoi de l'avion non du dans
le je  n'est-ce pas
trop, tout l'avion
reviendra une fois que moi
aussi où était-il en
Inde lequel ce n'est pas l'Inde
ouais c'est
déjà l'Inde les Européens
comme les Européens aiment tellement l'Inde
je ne suis pas
heran si je le dis  vous
que RIS signifie que l'oxygène est
une
attitude culturelle respectable, vous serez
choqué et vous aurez raison d'être
choqué, mais si je dis qu'en Inde, l'
entrée principale de la ville est réservée à certaines
personnes, à certains d'entre nous, car
les ombres de leur corps peuvent
salissez ceux qui
les traversent pour les gens de l'occidental ça sera
beau
non
euh êtes-vous un
in en Inde on dit enfants de
Dieu avant de dire
Chandal non en Inde on dit enfants de
Dieu maintenant c'est
pire avant de dire
Shand êtes-vous un
Shand oui  il n'y a pas
une semaine
sans il n'y a pas une semaine sans
Dieu enfant
brûlé ou battu ou volé ou
rouge un
indien
un indien sur
quatre est un chal et
intouchable cela
fait ce
Mak
[Musique]
oh
avant d'avance
spee spee étranger
viens je te veux  Bo
extérieur
[Rires]
précieux
pour
toi, tu aimes la nourriture indienne oui, c'est
vraiment la première fois que tu vas en Inde
oui et toi non c'est la première fois que tu joues
non je pensais que c'était le cas
je pensais que c'était tu avais l'air effrayé
j'ai
peur  non de quoi de l'
avion les gens dans l'
avion je ne
parle pas je ne parle pas trop
une fois que je parle trop je suis l'avion
à l'
arrière où c'était où en
Inde ce n'est pas l'Inde ici tout est dans
[  Musique]
Inde
[Musique]
Ma
pour
[Musique]
pari
[Musique] [
Musique]
elle [Musique
] Les
Européens aiment tellement l'Inde que je ne le suis
pas [
Musique] Les
peuples européens aiment tellement l'Inde que je ne le suis
pas
[Musique  ]
Européens Les Européens aiment tellement l'Inde
je ne suis
pas un
si je vous dis R si je vous dis que R est
dans
[Musique]
oent
[Musique] [
Musique]
L [
dis
[Musique]
le
candidat trouvera du travail plus facilement
que euh, est-ce que les enfants de Dieu sont le
prêtre du PO non est-ce vrai H
enfants de Dieu oh ouais est-ce vrai Mery bien
sûr bien sûr bien
sûr
non ils peuvent dormir tranquillement bien sûr non
ils peuvent dormir
tranquillement le
Brahman le Raj  rien ne
changera [Musique] euh les enfants de Dieu ont un PR
sont pauvres pas toujours légèrement la
peau tu aimes la nourriture indienne
oui j'aime
c'est la première fois que tu y vas
[Applaudissements]
L'Inde oui d'abord
et ta première fois dans la
pièce
non je
pensais  tu as regardé tu as l'air
effrayé
[Musique]
non
Amar
anthon
[Musique]
an